nous sommes ici dans le canton mulhouse
2 à un endroit qui est extrêmement
symbolique de ceux de ce canton bien
entendu c'est un canton dans lequel il
ya une vie de quartier très riche mais
au delà de ça c'est un canton qui est
ouvert et qui apporte une véritable
richesse à tout le département et même
au-delà
nous sommes ici dans le triangle on va
dire culturel du canton avec derrière
nous la cité de l'automobile qui est une
connexion unique au monde de véhicules
anciens qui attire énormément de public
de public qui vient de très loin pour
voir ce qui est unique dans le
département et même dans notre dans
notre pays et nous avons juste à côté le
noumatrouff qui est la salle de musiques
actuelles qui est elle même très réputé
pour ses concerts et cela sur un
périmètre large et encore un tout petit
peu plus loin il ya le parc des
expositions qui avec toutes ces
manifestations des journées d'octobre la
foire de printemps par exemple attire
des centaines de milliers de visiteurs
et ainsi on voit que le canton mulhouse
2 est un canton qui présente une
véritable opportunité pour notre
département avec la centaine et les
centaines de milliers de visiteurs qui
viennent pour profiter des richesses
qu'on y trouve bien évidemment pour cela
il faut permettre l'accessibilité de ce
canton et de ses infrastructures
et c'est ce à quoi on travaille avec le
département et avec la communauté
d'agglomération à travers le projet
d'échangeur dames et réseaux qui va
permettre de raccorder directement ce
quartier à la rd 432 sorte que ces
infrastructures qui attire des centaines
de milliers de personnes puissent être
beaucoup plus facilement accessible et
en même temps ça permettra de
désenclaver tout le quartier
le canton de mulhouse 2 comme on l'a vu
présente de véritables richesses qui
peuvent profiter bien sûr aux habitants
mais également à tous les habitants du
du département et même au-delà mais dans
ce canton il y a une richesse
fondamentale qui est la richesse humaine
et qui s'exprime à travers une vie
associative intense c'est pour ça que
nous nous retrouvons avec des
responsables d'associations devant la
maison des associations à laquelle je
consacre chaque année une partie de mon
fonds de soutien territoriales parce
qu'elles méritent vraiment que l'on
puisse la développer je suis entouré de
bernard mouton qui est le président de
la maison des associations et qui est
également le responsable local de
l'association vie libre
je suis aussi en compagnie de mon ami
joseph shen hongbo qui est le président
de l'association bout de suler 2007 une
association d'habitants qui sollicitent
les pouvoirs publics en leur indiquant
les problèmes qui sont à régler c'est
très utile également pour les
collectivités et qui est également
impliqué comme président du conseil
participatif
bref un véritable engagement citoyen et
j'ai à mon côté droit le président de
l'as red star mulhouse qui est un club
de football très très dynamiques
notamment grâce à son président et je
peux dire que charles et bien incarne à
mes côtés aujourd'hui tous les toutes
les associations qui s'impliquent sur ce
canton et qui permettent d'avoir une
vraie qualité de vie en proximité avec
les habitants et enfin je préciserai que
charles est également mon suppléant on
dit remplaçant au conseil départemental
et c'est une occasion pour moi de
préciser qu'il ya une autre forme
d'engagement auprès des habitants pour
les accompagner c'est celui des élus
c'est vrai que c'est pas toujours bien
vu mais je peux vous assurer que
ensemble nous faisons un travail qui est
apprécié par les habitants